in a brief recapitulation the words
taken individually at 100 comic and
lautsi the main one in quotation marks
click on it drops the voice here stops
for a microsecond the accent of the sentence
allah center your friend of the most
important words that condition the structure
of the sentence the sentence is  organized
in blocks of words that are linked
through the sign we have seen and
the pauses between one word and another
are written are defined as
this marker which therefore marks let's say
micro pause of the voice
I would like to add that Italian has a
particular case has a  particular
another peculiarity that seems
obvious to others, in short, for others it is not
so much that it is called who
the double consonants are called and the double
consonants have a configuration that
makes only one change the way in which
the consonants are pronounced.
consonant console itself but also the
preceding vowel for example classic
example that comes  proposed is that between
the difference between pole and therefore can
north pole for example a pole and chicken
as you can see not only changes the with
sonar and a consonant but also with a vowel
the first vowel of paul is open and
the only one therefore lasts longer is  or it is a
training accent then others then I have the
corresponding marker this that is, it is
given so it rests a second on the
vowel but suitable to work protected
strength the force a let's say to the
consonant ball moreover there are
also fundamental markers of the
details
let's say markers are are called
arrows use this as a technique
arrows for the voice in general which is an
SUV on top of the whole structure
then I will explain what it means because it
is of vital importance not of language
to pay attention to let's say the
subtleties that we ask for the voice to
give a certain meaning  of surprise of
of curiosity etcetera etcetera in
particular the classic ones are the
question mark the exclamation point
and the mi  o sign used for
the interrogation is an arrow it is this
here that is an arrow that goes towards
the other instead of and cackles
so it is a tone let's say ascending
then upwards
and instead the exclamation a
descending tone  downwards having
told you in a large premises there are some
markers but not all of them I would like to read
this text and give you the phonetic analysis
from the third same true lab slowly the
mid-day meal
is called lunch in Italy it is
generally the most important meal
of the day  even if it is necessary to
record a certain variation of the
custom
especially in large cities that for
work needs have transformed
lunch into a light snack consumed
outside the home in its traditional form
lunch includes several courses a first
course usually pasta a second course
more meat and  a side dish of
vegetables and potatoes followed by a dessert or
fruit this text you can analyze being
able to analyze the  text that just
elected according to the phonetic analysis to
find out about what was said
previously then put it into
practice
and the conclusion is the following scotch
what is the main purpose of the
phonetic analysis months phonetic of a text as
you will see if you decide to apply it
takes time but if  you will have completed it you
will have noticed an absolutely
fundamental thing and that is that you have heard
the same text many times
and it is a time well spent because you will
notice a whole series of things
that pay great attention to
detail generally escape when you read  or you
listen to a text even several times
so the main purpose is to
understand the local patterns that is the paths
that the voice follows to
transmit information for example
emphasize introduce ask a question
for example the mid-day meal
with a break is an introduction
not even Japanese for a topic, for
example, creates a block with famous
of introductory words in this
sense then in the analysis that you can
apply the flor an effort made in
Italian but it is thought that not of languages
in English as you can do with the cloth
and present are the Japanese Roman
an as the French with of course the r
lative  ownership or only in held
some markers or but not all so
it is not just a matter of learning the
single words but also and above all
knowing how to pronounce them manage
within a single announced and therefore a
sentence the rest is just a matter of
practice that is more yes  speak and it is better
therefore to pay attention to the cuts is the
main thing and I would like to add that
very often we talk about reduction
afterwards it has to do with reduction of the twentieth century
mark
if instead we spoke spread
breakthrough laying the foundations to found
one's own one hundred would perhaps be
better migrants than  to that of hard but if
we start well it is important to
permeate the fact that for me it is
absolutely important c  starting well
starts well and when i go to 9
thanks see you next video